today we're talking about contextual
traces for cloud logging cloud
certifications and next 21 i'm carter
morgan and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
the need for relevant and contextual
telemetry data to support online
services has grown in the last decade as
businesses undergo digital
transformation
distributed tracing is a key capability
for improving application performance
and reliability as noted in sre best
practices today we're making it easier
for you to understand what is happening
within your applications by making trace
information available directly in cloud
logging
this past august 50 service members
began a 12-week google cloud-sponsored
certification learning journey towards
achieving the google cloud associate
cloud engineer certification
participants had access to online
on-demand learning assets bi-weekly
technical review sessions taught by
google engineers and mentoring through
google groups to learn more about this
initiative to help upskill veterans for
an evolving job market and the value of
cloud certifications check out the blog
if you missed the fun from next 21
you're now able to check out all that
content on demand from keynotes to demos
click on the link to be a part of the
action what a year as 2021 winds down
we're preparing for 2022 by taking a
deep breath and looking back at all
we've accomplished since january we hope
you'll take the next few weeks to do
what you can for yourself and we'll see
you in 2022 with the lowest latency news
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud